le conseil a enfin concédé un autre et
après les exercices de découverte un peu
de mise en pratique à plaisir certain
faisait ce week-end leurs premiers pas
sur scène
les participants sont tous présents en
binôme les parents accompagnent leurs
enfants ou inversement
j'aime bien parce que quand on fait du
théâtre en collectif on peut rencontrer
d'autres gens voire des moments ensemble
autre que manger regarder sa montre
faire les doigts a toujours regardé sa
montre là j'ai vraiment apprécié le fait
d'être ensemble et de passer à un moment
tous les deux c'est mon côté mon cadeau
de noël donc il m'a dit tiens je vais
t'offrir ça tu vas venir avec moi au
théâtre moi comme j'en fais à côté j'ai
déjà fait des exercices et du coup j'ai
je réexplique un petit peu j'avais envie
de le partager ça avec elle est là
dessus
titouan mon petit garçon s'est greffée
avec mon mari
[Musique]
un atelier parents-enfants imaginé par
l'association plaisir oise pour la
promotion du théâtre et du spectacle
vivant
le temps d'une journée les bases ont été
abordés travail sur le corps la voix ou
encore les émotions pour certains c'est
de découvrir la passion de l'autre de
mieux comprendre aussi du cool pourquoi
cette passion pourquoi ça peut être
aussi prenants l'atelier était proposé
pour la deuxième année consécutive par
l'association plaisir oise un prochain
stage est prévu au mois de mars destiné
cette fois aux adultes et je ne sais tu
[Applaudissements]